Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Tell them to meet me at Egbert's Stone, near the woods where Somerset meets Wiltshire. Tell them to bring whatever weapons they can find, knives, cudgels, even pitchforks if they have them. Tell them to lift up their hearts and summon their courage. For too long have we lived in fear of the Danes. No longer. At Egbert's Stone, we will stand and fight. For God, for Wessex, for England.
感谢您收听《一切皆历史》。要想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。告诉他们在大埃格伯特石（Egbert's Stone）见我，就在萨默塞特与威尔特郡交界的树林附近。告诉他们带上能找到的任何武器，刀具、大棒，如果有的话甚至带上干草叉。告诉他们振作精神，鼓起勇气。我们生活在对丹麦人的恐惧中已经太久了。绝不退缩。在大埃格伯特石，我们将挺身战斗。为了上帝，为了威塞克斯，为了英格兰。
That Dominic Sandbrook was an extract from a top new book, Fury of the Vikings, by a top historian, namely yourself. So the latest in your series of books written for children, Adventures in History. Adventures in Time. Adventures in Time, Dominic, sorry. Brilliant stuff. That is exactly how, when I was a child in Wessex, that's exactly the kind of stuff that I read when I learned about King Alfred, because i was devoted to alfred um i grew up near wilton which became the the kind of the great dynastic um center for for the for the women of wessex and so i felt incredibly proud of alfred i kind of felt that he was my king um and i'm absolutely thrilled to be doing this episode ever since we started doing this podcast i'm glad to have stirred such feelings in you tom i laughed at you when you
多米尼克·桑德布鲁克，那是节选自一本优秀的畅销新书《维京人的愤怒》（Fury of the Vikings），作者是一位杰出的历史学家，也就是你本人。所以这是你为儿童撰写的历史系列丛书中的最新一本，即“历史大冒险”。“时间大冒险”。抱歉，多米尼克，是“时间大冒险”。太棒了。这完全就是我在威塞克斯度过童年时，当了解到阿尔弗雷德大帝时所读到的那种内容，因为我非常崇拜阿尔弗雷德。嗯，我在威尔顿附近长大，那里后来成为了威塞克斯女性的重要王朝中心，所以我为阿尔弗雷德感到无比自豪。我某种程度上觉得他就是我的国王，嗯，我非常高兴能做这一期节目。自从我们开始做这个播客以来，我很高兴能在你心中激起这样的情感，汤姆。我曾嘲笑你，当你
implied that alexander the great was um a worthwhile model for young boys and girls but with this i completely agree that alfred is an absolute model and uh everyone should try and live like alfred for those people who don't know i've been doing a series of children's books aimed at people between i don't know eight and've been doing a series of children's books aimed at people between, I don't know, 8 and 12 or something. And this one is, as Tom says, called Fury of the Vikings. And Alfred is one of the great characters in it because there is an argument, isn't there, Tom? The battle against the Viking, the fight against the Vikings was the foundational moment in the creation of something called England and Englishness. And the idea of Englishness doesn't make any sense unless you understand it as a reaction to the landing of
暗示亚历山大大帝是年轻男孩和女孩们一个值得效仿的榜样时，但对于这一点，我完全赞同阿尔弗雷德绝对是一个典范，呃，每个人都应该尝试像阿尔弗雷德那样生活。对于那些不知道的人，我一直在创作一套儿童书，针对的群体是，我不知道，大约八岁到。一直在创作一套儿童书，针对的群体是，我不知道，八岁到十二岁左右的孩子。正如汤姆所说，这本书名为《维京人的愤怒》。阿尔弗雷德是其中的伟大人物之一，因为有一个论点，不是吗，汤姆？对维京人的抗争，对维京人的战斗是建立被称为英格兰和英格兰性这一概念的奠基时刻。而如果没有将它理解为对来自丹麦和挪威等地的
so many boats from Denmark and Norway and whatnot and the long ships. I mean, I think I would go further than that. So the passage I read, that is Alfred summoning the West Saxons to join him and they will go on to fight a great battle at Eddington. But this is after probably the most famous thing associated with Alfred, which is the burning of the cakes. He's been attacked by the Vikings. He's fled into the marshes of Athelni and he's gazing into the fire, trying to work out how to defeat the Vikings and he burns the cakes. And then he goes out and he has this stirring peroration, which Dominic has just written up for us. So it's all great stuff.
众多船只以及长船登陆的一种反应，那么英格兰性的概念就毫无意义。我的意思是，我觉得我可以更进一步。所以我刚才读的那段话，是阿尔弗雷德召唤西撒克逊人加入他，他们随后将在爱丁顿（Eddington）进行一场大战。但这是在发生可能与阿尔弗雷德最著名的事件——也就是烧焦蛋糕——之后。他遭到维京人的袭击。他逃到了阿瑟尼（Athelney）的沼泽地，凝视着炉火，苦思冥想如何击败维京人，结果把蛋糕烤焦了。然后他走出去，发表了这段激昂的结语，多米尼克刚刚为我们写下了这些。所以这一切都很棒。
But I think that the history behind this is actually, I mean, it couldn't be more dramatic. And we've talked quite a lot over the course of this series about whether there are truly decisive moments, whether there are episodes or events that if they'd gone differently, history would have been radically different. And I do think that had Alfred died, had he been captured by the Vikings and executed, or had he fallen in battle, or had he given up and fled as so many of the other kings of the various Anglo-Saxon kingdoms had done i think i think the history of england and therefore of much of the rest of the planet would be considerably different i really
但我认为这背后的历史实际上，我的意思是，它再戏剧化不过了。在这个系列节目中，我们花了很多时间讨论是否存在真正具决定性的时刻，是否存在这样一些剧集或事件，如果它们的结局不同，历史将发生根本性的改变。我确实认为，如果阿尔弗雷德死了，如果他被维京人俘虏并处决，或者他在战斗中阵亡，或者像众多其他盎格鲁-撒克逊王国的国王那样放弃并逃跑，我认为，我认为英格兰的历史，从而也是地球上其他大部分地方的历史将会大不相同，我真的
do think that would there even be an and somewhere called england would that word exist that is that is the question um i mean i certainly think the language that we're speaking now would probably not exist um it would be a very different thing. So I think that the reign of Alfred is really, really important. I mean, there is a problem, I think, in overhyping Alfred, because that's what the Victorians did. So there's a sense in which our image of Alfred is so strongly mediated through the devotion that the Victorians felt for him, as this kind of flaxen-haired Victorian Christian gentleman, which is very much the image who basically invented everything. Didn't he invent, he invented clocks, the Royal Navy,
这么认为。甚至还会有一个叫做英格兰的地方吗？那个词还会存在吗？这就是问题所在。嗯，我当然认为我们现在说的语言可能就不会存在了，它会是完全不同的东西。所以我认为阿尔弗雷德的统治真的非常非常重要。我的意思是，我认为在过度吹捧阿尔弗雷德方面存在一个问题，因为那是维多利亚时代的人所做的。所以在某种程度上，我们对阿尔弗雷德的印象在很大程度上是通过维多利亚时代的人对他倾注的炽热情感来传达的，他被塑造成一个金发碧眼的维多利亚时代基督教绅士，这非常符合那个基本上发明了一切的形象。难道不是吗，他发明了时钟、皇家海军、
books, English. Oxford University. Yes. I mean, basically everything. But I do think that he's great. I mean, if the word great means anything, I think Alfred was great. And that word is actually, you know, the association of Alfred with the idea of greatness is quite, I mean, it goes quite a long way back. I mean, it goes back to, I think, 13th century. I think it's Matthew Paris who first does that and then really takes wing with the Tudors. But simultaneously, it's interesting that the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle, which is our main source for vast sweeps of early medieval history in Britain, and which basically Alfred started up. When Alfred dies, it doesn't give him any great encomium. I mean, it doesn't kind of cast him as this great figure that we subsequently salute. And I think that
书籍、英语、牛津大学。是的。我的意思是，基本上一切。但我确实认为他很伟大。我的意思是，如果“伟大”这个词有什么意义的话，我认为阿尔弗雷德就是伟大的。而这个词实际上，你知道，阿尔弗雷德与伟大概念的联系相当久远，我的意思是，它可以追溯到，我认为是13世纪。我想是马修·帕里斯（Matthew Paris）首先这样称呼他，然后到了都铎王朝时期真正流行开来。但与此同时，有趣的是，《盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史》（Anglo-Saxon Chronicle）——这是我们了解英国中世纪早期庞大历史的主要来源，也是阿尔弗雷德基本上开创的——在阿尔弗雷德去世时，并没有给予他任何崇高的颂词。我的意思是，它并没有将他塑造成我们后来致敬的伟大人物。我认为
that reflects the fact that perhaps it required the distance of centuries properly to appreciate the full scale of his achievement. They don't know what we know. So they don't know that Alfred's heirs, presumably, when they're writing, they don't know that Alfred's heirs are going to go on and build this. They're going to fulfill his dream, as it were. So people who've seen the TV series The Last Kingdom, based on the Bernard Cornwell historical novels, will know that in the series, Alfred is always going on about his dream of England. Yeah. And obviously, I couldn't resist putting that in my children's book. Well, also, Dominic, people have listened to our episode on World Cup of English Kings
这反映了这样一个事实：也许需要几个世纪的距离，才能真正充分体会到他成就的全部规模。他们并不知道我们所知道的。所以他们并不知道阿尔弗雷德的继承人们，大概在他们写作时，他们并不知道阿尔弗雷德的继承人将继续建立这个国家。可以说，他们将实现他的梦想。因此，看过根据伯纳德·康韦尔（Bernard Cornwell）历史小说改编的电视剧《最后的王国》（The Last Kingdom）的人会知道，在该剧中，阿尔弗雷德一直在谈论他的英格兰梦想。是的。当然，我忍不住把它写进了我的儿童书中。对了，多米尼克，人们听过我们关于英格兰国王世界杯的节目
and Queens. Yeah. The winner was Athelstan, commonly thought to be the first king of England. That's certainly how we cast him, who is the grandson of Alfred. Yeah. And deeply shaped by him. Alfred did not feature in the World Cup of English. We had a massive argument about that, didn't we, Tom?
和女王。是的。获胜者是埃塞尔斯坦（Athelstan），普遍被认为是英格兰的第一位国王。我们当然也是这样塑造他的，他是阿尔弗雷德的孙子。是的。深受他的影响。阿尔弗雷德没有出现在英格兰世界杯中。我们为此进行了一场激烈的争论，对吧，汤姆？
We did, because he was not a king of England. He's a king of Wessex, which is the... So we should just... So let's get on to Alfred. Let's get on to Alfred's life. Right. So we should do the Vikings as well. We're going to talk about the Vikings in the second half, aren't we?
是的，因为他不是英格兰的国王。他是威塞克斯的国王，也就是……所以我们应该……那么让我们继续谈谈阿尔弗雷德。让我们谈谈阿尔弗雷德的一生。好的。所以我们也应该谈谈维京人。我们将在下半场谈论维京人，对吧？
Because we're going to bring them on stage. I mean, a hero needs antagonists. And I think Alfred's story does depend on the Vikings in the second half, aren't we? Because we're going to bring them on stage. I mean, a hero needs antagonists. And I think Alfred's story does depend on the Vikings, on these sort of gigantic, black-bearded... Or blonde-bearded. Well, I suppose they would have been blonde-bearded, yeah. But they... Well, in the Lady Bird book that I read when I was little.
因为我们要把他们请上台。我的意思是，英雄需要对手。我认为阿尔弗雷德的故事确实取决于下半场的维京人，对吧？因为我们要把他们请上台。我的意思是，英雄需要对手。我认为阿尔弗雷德的故事确实取决于维京人，取决于那些巨大的、黑胡子的……或者是金胡子的。嗯，我想他们应该是金胡子的，对吧。但他们……好吧，在我小时候读的Lady Bird书里。
Exactly. I'm sure they were black-bearded because all the Anglo-Saxons were blonde. Blonde, yes. Looking like Prince Albert but that sort of antagonism that's what fires your imagination that's what must have been what fired your imagination
没错。我确信他们是黑胡子的，因为所有的盎格鲁-撒克逊人都金发碧眼。金发的，是的。长得像阿尔伯特亲王一样，但那种对抗正是点燃你想象力的东西，那一定就是点燃你想象力的东西
towards the fact that you know these terrifying figures with horned helmets and so as a child in the books I read the Vikings were terrifying, they were terrifying adversaries who would disembowel you or pull your guts out or whatever, shoot you full of arrows and then I kind of
让你意识到，你知道，这些戴着有角头盔的恐怖人物，所以在童年时我读的书里，维京人是可怕的，他们是可怕的对手，会把你的内脏剖出来或者把你的肠子拉出来之类，用箭把你射成筛子，然后我有点
graduated to books that said oh no that wasn't true at all these are all um you know they're kind of fantasies manufactured by uh by monks uh in fact that yes the wonderful culture that they spread and all this kind of and now i've definitely gone back to yeah they were terrified i mean you know their culture was extraordinary but it was extraordinary in a terrifying way. And I completely agree. The measure of the drama of Alfred escaping the assault on Chippenham, getting to Walthamlea, winning at Eddington, is entirely dependent on the fact that the penalties for defeat were horrendous. But as you say, we will come to the Vikings.
过渡到这样的书籍，它们说：“哦，不，那完全不是真的，这些全都是，你知道，由僧侣虚构的幻想；事实上，是的，他们传播了精彩的文化以及所有这类东西。”而现在我绝对回到了“是的，他们确实很可怕”的观点，我是说，你知道他们的文化非同寻常，但它是以一种可怕的方式非同寻常。我完全同意。阿尔弗雷德逃脱对奇本纳姆（Chippenham）的袭击、到达沃尔瑟姆利（Walthamlea）、在爱丁顿取胜，这一系列戏剧性的程度完全取决于战败的惩罚极其残酷这一事实。但正如你所说，我们将会谈到维京人。
So we don't have a unitary state of England, do we, in the 9th century? Competing kingdoms. So you've got North will come to the Vikings. So we don't have a unitary state of England, do we, in the 9th century? Competing kingdoms. So you've got Northumbria in the north. You have Mercia, which is the kind of, on paper, looks like the giant because it's kind of sprawling over the Midlands. You've got East Anglia and you've got Wessex, haven't you? And Wessex is the coming power. The others have all had a moment in the sun,
所以我们在9世纪并没有一个统一的英格兰国，对吧？各个王国相互竞争。所以在北部，你会……我们将谈到维京人。所以在9世纪并没有一个统一的英格兰国，对吧？各个王国相互竞争。所以在北部有诺森布里亚。你有麦西亚，它在纸面上看起来像个庞然大物，因为它在米德兰兹（Midlands）蔓延。你有东盎吉利亚，你还有威塞克斯，对吧？威塞克斯正在成为新兴力量。其他的都曾有过辉煌时刻，
particularly Northumbria and Mercia. But they're in decline. And Wessex, which has kind of been, not exactly, a whipping boy is too strong, isn't it? But Wessex has been a slightly junior kingdom, I would say. Is that fair, Tom? A slow developer. Yeah.
特别是诺森布里亚和麦西亚。但它们正在衰落。而威塞克斯，它一直以来，不能完全说是……说它是受气包有点过分了，对吧？但我可以说威塞克斯一直是一个稍微次要一点的王国。这样说公平吗，汤姆？一个缓慢发展的国家。是的。
You won't hear a word against Wessex, of course. So in Chipping Norton, where I live, you can vote for the Wessex Regional where i live you you can you can vote for the wessex regionalist party presumably you would vote for them yeah i think i would i think i would well but i'm mercy and as well my my um my ancestry reaches back to mercia of course i am an anglo-saxon figure so the northumbrians the mercians the east by definition, are Anglians, Angles, Angli. And the Wessex is the kingdom of the West Saxons, so they're Saxon. They essentially speak the same language.
当然，你不会听到任何人说威塞克斯的坏话。所以在奇平诺顿（Chipping Norton），也就是我住的地方，你可以投票给威塞克斯地区……也就是我住的地方，你可以投票给威塞克斯地区主义党，大概你会投票给他们吧？是的，我想我会的，我想我会的。不过我也是麦西亚人，我的……我的祖先可以追溯到麦西亚，当然，我是一个盎格鲁-撒克逊人，所以诺森布里亚人、麦西亚人、东盎吉利亚人，按定义来说，都是盎格利亚人、盎格鲁人、盎格里人。而威塞克斯是西撒克逊人的王国，所以他们是撒克逊人。他们基本上说的是同一种语言。
They have the same religion. They have the same kind of foundation myths. So I think they feel a certain kind of kinship. And this will become very important to Alfred. But at the same time, the opportunity to fight each other is also very important. And basically, they play by rules, I think. I mean, obviously, battles between, say, the Mercians or the West Saxons or whoever are murderous when they get there.
他们有相同的宗教信仰。他们有相似的奠基神话。所以我认为他们有一种亲切感。这对于阿尔弗雷德来说将变得非常重要。但与此同时，互相战斗的机会也非常重要。基本上，我认为他们是按规则行事的。我的意思是，显然，比如说麦西亚人和西撒克逊人或任何人之间的战斗，一旦打起来都是极其血腥的。
But there's the slight element of a kind of seasonal fixture about it. You know, you summon your men they take time to come there you go out you have a battle you come back uh and this is why the vikings are so devastating is that they don't play by the rules and there's a sort of sense isn't it doesn't uh the uh bead the venerable bead um northumbrian doesn't he call them the gens anglorum or something like that so yes there is there is a sense that they know that they've got something in common, like their language and customs. And as you say, they've got this sense they've come over the sea,
但这其中带有轻微的季节性赛事的成分。你知道，你召集你的手下，他们需要时间集结，然后你出去打一仗，再回来。这就是为什么维京人如此具有毁灭性，因为他们不按牌理出牌。而且有一种感觉，不是吗？难道伯德，尊贵的伯德——诺森布里亚人——不是称他们为gens anglorum（盎格鲁人的种族）或类似的名字吗？所以是的，确实有一种感觉，他们知道彼此有共同点，比如语言和习俗。正如你所说，他们有一种横渡大海的感觉，
which they had done sort of 200 or 300 years earlier. But there's never been in England, nobody has ever really even thought to do away with the competing kingdoms and have a single state. There is this title, the Bretwalder, which is the kind of the supreme king. And essentially, to begin with, it's Northumbrian kings who tend to claim that title, then Mercian ones. And Alfred's grandfather, Egbert, he claims it for Wessex so um 825 there's a great battle where he defeats Beornwolf the king of Mercia and the kind of the strain of the Tolkienist in all this is not um coincidental because of Tolkien was absolutely steeped in all this stuff
这大约在200或300年前就已经发生过了。但在英格兰从未有过，从来没有人真正想过要废除那些相互竞争的王国并建立一个单一的国家。有一个称号叫“布雷特瓦尔达”（Bretwalder），也就是最高国王的意思。基本上，起初往往是诺森布里亚的国王宣称这个称号，然后是麦西亚的国王。阿尔弗雷德的祖父埃格伯特（Egbert）为威塞克斯宣称了这一称号。所以在825年，发生了一场大战，他击败了麦西亚国王比恩沃尔夫（Beornwolf），这其中托尔金主义的痕迹并非巧合，因为托尔金对这一切深有研究
so Beornwolf bear bear wolf so as a result of that battle, by 1829, he's being hailed as the Bretwalder, the paramount king in England. And he has essentially brought the previously independent kingdoms of Kent, of Sussex, of Essex under his rule. And he's kind of got Mercia to acknowledge a degree of of sovereignty but i think what's interesting in the wake of this is that oddly relations between mercy and wessex seem to have improved and it may be that he he doesn't force his supremacy too brutally or too kind of aggressively uh and actually kind of works to build bridges between um between wessex and mercia um and this this will be very important in the story of alfred one thing we haven't mentioned kind of works to build bridges between Wessex and Mercia.
所以比恩沃尔夫，熊狼。因此在那场战役之后，到829年，他被尊为布雷特瓦尔达，即英格兰的最高国王。他基本上将以前独立的肯特、萨塞克斯、埃塞克斯王国置于他的统治之下。他让麦西亚在一定程度上承认了他的主权。但我认为有趣的是，在此之后，奇怪的是，麦西亚和威塞克斯之间的关系似乎有所改善，这可能是因为他没有过于残酷或过于具有侵略性地强推他的霸权，实际上是在努力在威塞克斯和麦西亚之间搭建桥梁。这在阿尔弗雷德的故事中将非常重要。我们还没有提到的一点是，在努力在威塞克斯和麦西亚之间搭建桥梁。
And this will be very important in the story of Alfred. One thing we haven't mentioned, Tom, just to put this into context, these people are all Christian, aren't they? Completely Christian, yes. Very, very, very devoutly Christian. It's really important to them that they're Christian. I mean, that's the big difference, I would say. So when I've given school talks and stuff about my books, the children always say the Anglo-Saxons and the Vikings look so similar.
这在阿尔弗雷德的故事中将非常重要。汤姆，我们还没提到的一点，为了把这放在时代背景下，这些人都是基督徒，对吧？完全是基督徒，是的。非常、非常、非常虔诚的基督徒。信仰基督教对他们来说非常重要。我的意思是，这是最大的区别，我想说。所以当我在学校做关于我的书的演讲时，孩子们总是说盎格鲁-撒克逊人和维京人看起来太像了。
They wear the same clothes. They have the same swords. What's the difference? I mean, obviously to them, the single biggest difference, apart from any linguistic differences or whatever, is that the Anglo-Saxons are Christians and that's how they see themselves. And when they talk about the Danes or whatever, what we would call the Vikings, they usually call them the heathens or the pagans. That's the thing that strikes them about them, isn't it? Yeah. They take it very seriously. Alfred in particular, the king about whom we know the most, there's an absolute sense that he feels
他们穿一样的衣服。他们用一样的剑。有什么区别？我的意思是，对他们来说，显而易见，除了任何语言上的差异或其他什么之外，最大的区别在于盎格鲁-撒克逊人是基督徒，他们就是这样看待自己的。当他们谈论丹麦人或其他我们称之为维京人的人时，他们通常称他们为异教徒。这就是让他们对这些人印象深刻的地方，对吧？是的。他们对此非常严肃。特别是阿尔弗雷德，这位我们了解最多的国王，有一种绝对的感觉，他觉得
that he has been appointed to the throne by God and that he will therefore be answerable to God for the state of his kingdom and the people within it. And I think that you get a sense definitely with Alfred, again, because we know enough about his character and actually about the physical ailments that over the course of his reign affect him. He seems to have experienced, I think, the kind of the tension between the obligations on him as a Christian and the obligations to defend his people as a kind of, it seems to have induced a considerable strain in him, I think. But it is important to him. You know, the tension between, you know, put up your sword and having to draw your sword. Alfred, I think, is troubled by this throughout his reign. But the other thing, Dominic, I was just going to say
他被上帝任命为国王，因此他将为他的王国的状况和其中的人民向上帝负责。我认为你绝对能从阿尔弗雷德身上感受到这一点，同样是因为我们对他的性格以及在他统治期间影响他的身体疾病有足够的了解。他似乎经历过，我认为，作为基督徒的义务与作为……捍卫人民的义务之间的紧张关系，这似乎在他身上引发了相当大的压力，我认为。但这对他很重要。你知道，放下剑与不得不拔出剑之间的紧张关系。我认为阿尔弗雷德在他整个统治期间都为此感到困扰。但另一件事，多米尼克，我正要说的是
is that the church is important to any king in early medieval England, because they provide the literate clerks who can draw up the charters and who can provide the kind of the nascent bureaucracy that gives to the various Anglo-Saxon kingdoms their claim to be a part of a kind of broader Christian civilization. And again, that is very, very important to Alfred because, and it's so important. So he's born in 849 in Wantage in Oxfordshire. And his father is Aethelwulf. Yeah, who is the first, I think the first son to succeed his father as king of Wessex for about a century or more. Yeah, because that gives you a sense.
对于中世纪早期的任何英格兰国王来说，教会都很重要，因为他们提供了能够起草宪章的识字文吏，并能提供一种初露端倪的官僚体制，使各个盎格鲁-撒克逊王国拥有宣称自己是更广泛的基督教文明一部分的资本。再说一次，这对阿尔弗雷德来说非常非常重要，因为，而且这太重要了。所以他于849年出生在牛津郡的旺蒂奇（Wantage）。他的父亲是埃塞尔乌尔夫（Aethelwulf）。是的，他大概是大约一个世纪或更长时间里，第一位继承父亲王位成为威塞克斯国王的儿子。是的，因为这能让你体会到这一点。
It was very unstable. I mean, there were different families kind of fighting. There's not one dynasty going all the way through. It's very Game of Thrones. But Aethelwulf succeeds. Alfred, there's no sense that Alfred has been born to be king though, is there? Because he's not the oldest son. No, he's the youngest of five brothers and one sister. But I think the measure of how
当时非常不稳定。我的意思是，有不同的家族在某种程度上互相征战。并没有一个朝代贯穿始终。这非常像《权力的游戏》。但埃塞尔武夫成功了。阿尔弗雷德，人们并不会觉得阿尔弗雷德生来就是国王，对吧？因为他不是长子。不，他是五个兄弟和一个姐妹中最小的。但我认为，从某种程度上来说
confident Aethelwulf is in the stability of his realm is that, first of all, he sends Alfred off to Rome as a very young boy. The age of four. The age of four, to be where he's received by the Pope Leo IV, who bestows great honours on him. Yeah, gives him the sword and the robe of a Roman consul. And that sort of, I mean, obviously they are living, I mean, they are literally living, Tom, in the ruins of the Western Roman Empire. But there's still a sense, isn't there, that there's enormous status and prestige associated with Rome and Roman-ness.
埃塞尔武夫对他的王国的稳定性有多大信心，首先，他在阿尔弗雷德还是个非常小的男孩时就把他送到了罗马。四岁时。四岁时，去拜见教皇利奥四世，教皇赐予他极高的荣誉。是的，送给他一把剑和一件罗马执政官的袍子。这有点像，我的意思是，很明显他们生活在，我的意思是，他们字面意义上就生活在，汤姆，西罗马帝国的废墟之中。但人们仍然有一种感觉，不是吗，那就是与罗马和罗马性相关的巨大地位和威望。
And for a little boy, I mean, who knows? It must have been overwhelming. Do you remember this? Do you remember things that happened when you were four? I mean, maybe you do if people are always talking about it. You think you do. And I'm sure for, you know, we don't, I mean, it's difficult to delve too much into Alfred's psychology.
而对一个小男孩来说，我的意思是，谁知道呢？这一定曾让他感到不知所措。你还记得这个吗？你还记得你四岁时发生的事情吗？我的意思是，也许你记得，如果人们总是在谈论它的话。你以为你记得。我确信对于，你知道的，我们不会，我的意思是，很难深入探究阿尔弗雷德的心理。
But for a little, a four-year-old boy surrounded by servants and bodyguards and whatnot. Yeah. To be there with the Pope in front of him, the Pope anoints him, I think, puts a hand on his forehead and says, here's all the stuff of a consul. That's a pretty big deal, isn't it? It is a big deal. And rammed home by the fact that two years later, Alfred goes to Rome again. I mean, unbelievably, with his father, who has left one of his sons as kind of regent. He's kind of slightly divvied the kingdom up between two of his two elder sons. And he goes off on pilgrimage, again taking Alfred.
但对于一个被仆人、保镖之类的人包围的四岁小男孩来说。是的。与教皇在一起，教皇在他面前，教皇为他涂圣油，我想，把手放在他的额头上说，这里有执政官的一切标志。这真是件大事，不是吗？这确实是一件大事。两年后，阿尔弗雷德再次前往罗马，这一事实更加印证了这一点。我的意思是，难以置信的是，他和他的父亲一起去，他的父亲把他的一个儿子留下来当摄政王。他把王国在某种程度上分给了他的两个大儿子。然后他去朝圣，再次带上了阿尔弗雷德。
Rome, I think, has a huge impact on Alfred. It's a kind of model of the kind of grandeur that it is possible for a Christian city to possess. But then coming back from Rome, they go through Francia. So the, the, the Frankish empire that had been founded,
罗马，我认为，对阿尔弗雷德产生了巨大的影响。这是一座基督教城市可能拥有的那种宏伟气势的某种典范。但随后从罗马回来时，他们穿过了法兰克尼亚。所以，那个由法兰克帝国建立的，
you know, brought to greatness by Charlemagne. And they visit the court of Charles, the bald. You had a full head of hair. You had a full head of hair. Yeah. So they called him Charles, the bald. And we don't know if that was a joke or what. And Arthur Wolfe marries
你知道的，被查理曼大帝推向辉煌的帝国。他们拜访了秃头查理的宫廷。你有一头浓密的头发。你有一头浓密的头发。是的。所以他们叫他秃头查理。我们不知道这是个笑话还是怎么回事。埃塞尔武夫娶了
one of Charles's daughters called Judith. But again, I think the effect of seeing the court of the heirs of Charlemagne again must have had a very, very powerful impact on Alfred, and given him a sense of what it was to be a Christian king that will never leave him. So when he gets back, I mean, there's one thing we know about him. Well, there's one story that's often told about him as a boy, isn't there, Tom? Which is that, I mean, you read this in all the sort of children's accounts, children's sort of storybook accounts of Alfred the Great, that his mother calls all her sons to her side. And she's holding this beautiful illustrated volume of Anglo-Saxon poetry. And she says, I should give this to the first boy who can read it.
查理的一个女儿，名叫朱迪思。但同样，我认为看到查理曼大帝后裔宫廷的情景，必定对阿尔弗雷德产生了非常非常强大的影响，让他对成为一个基督教国王有了一种永生难忘的感悟。所以当他回来时，我的意思是，关于他我们知道有一件事。好吧，关于他作为一个男孩，人们经常流传这样一个故事，不是吗，汤姆？那就是，我的意思是你在所有关于阿尔弗雷德大帝的儿童读物、儿童故事书里都能读到这一点，他的母亲把所有的儿子叫到身边。她手里拿着这本精美插图的盎格鲁-撒克逊诗歌集。她说，我应该把这个送给第一个能读懂它的男孩。
And Alfred is absolutely determined to overhaul his older siblings. And he says, how do I, how do I, you know, she says, well, you have to learn everything in the book. And the story goes that he borrows the book and he takes it to a monk who's teaching him about the Bible. And the monk explains to him what's in the book. Alfred learns it all by heart. Obviously dead easy to learn the contents of a book in just a few days, Tom. And then a few days later, he goes to his mother and says, oh, I can tell you what's in the book. And he recites it all.
阿尔弗雷德绝对决心超越他的年长兄弟们。他说，我怎么，我怎么，你知道的，她说，好吧，你必须学会书中的一切。故事说他借了这本书，把它带给一个教他圣经的修道士。修道士向他解释了书中的内容。阿尔弗雷德把它背得滚瓜烂熟。显然，在短短几天内学会一本书的内容是极其容易的，汤姆。然后几天后，他去找他母亲说，哦，我能告诉你书里有什么。然后他把全篇背诵了下来。
And she gives him the book. And the children's stories say he keeps the book by his bedside for the rest of his life. Such a moving story. But this is in the life of Alfred, isn't it? There's a hint of this in the life of Alfred by his friend and sort of protege and devotee, the Welsh Bishop Asser, who clearly worshipped Alfred. Indisputably, one of the reasons why posterity has such a positive take on Alfred is the fact that Alfred, a bit like Churchill, wrote his... He controlled the sources. And so Alfred commissions the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle,
她把书给了他。儿童故事说，他余生都把这本书放在床头。多么感人的故事。但这在阿尔弗雷德的生平中，不是吗？在阿尔弗雷德的朋友、某种程度上的门生兼崇拜者——威尔士主教阿塞尔所写的阿尔弗雷德传记中，有一点这样的暗示，阿塞尔显然崇拜阿尔弗雷德。毫无疑问，后世对阿尔弗雷德有如此正面评价的原因之一，就是阿尔弗雷德有点像丘吉尔，他写了自己的……他控制了史料来源。因此，阿尔弗雷德委托编写了《盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史》，
but he also commissions this extraordinary life by this Welsh bishop, Asser, which is pretty unique. We don't really have anything comparable. And so we do get these anecdotes. And presumably this story must have come from Alfred. And it shows him in a very good light. So surprise, surprise. What it also suggests, though, is alfred learns it by the poetry by heart but he doesn't learn to read well that's
但他也委托这位威尔士主教阿塞尔撰写了这部非凡的传记，这相当独特。我们真的没有什么可以与之相比的东西。所以我们确实得到了这些轶事。据推测，这个故事一定来自阿尔弗雷德本人。它把他描绘成一个非常好的人。所以，不出所料。然而，这也表明，阿尔弗雷德虽然把诗歌背得滚瓜烂熟，但他并没有学会很好地阅读，这就是
the fascinating thing isn't it yes because there's no way you can learn to read in three days so this is this is something that that i think weighs on alfred over the course of his childhood and then into his his youth that that he can't't read. He would like to learn to read. He would like to learn to write. He would like to be able to translate from English into Latin or vice versa much better than he actually can. And this is something that over the course... He's an absolute exemplar of adult education.
最迷人的地方，不是吗？是的，因为你不可能在三天内学会阅读，所以这是，我认为这在阿尔弗雷德的童年乃至青年时期一直压在他心头的一件事，那就是他不会读书。他想学读书。他想学写作。他想能够把英语翻译成拉丁语，或者反过来，比他实际能做到的要好得多。这是随着时间的推移……他绝对是成人教育的典范。
Over the course of his life, even when he's busy fighting Vikings and issuing charters and building new towns and all kinds of things, all the stuff that Anglo-Saxon kings have to do, he is also committing himself to this learning. And the idea of it. But he's also associated with poetry, with literacy, with education, with religious institutions, all these kinds of things. And that gives him a dimension that just a warlord wouldn't necessarily have. Yeah. I mean, I think that there are lots of Anglo-Saxon kings that are very good at killing people in war. And Alfred is very, very good at killing people in war. And he is perfectly capable of behaving very brutally when he needs to. You know, the idea that he was a Victorian gentleman is not true.
在他的一生中，甚至当他忙于与维京人战斗、发布特许状、建立新城镇以及做各种各样的事情时——所有盎格鲁-撒克逊国王都必须做的事情，他也一直致力于这种学习。以及它的理念。但他也与诗歌、识字、教育、宗教机构所有这些事情联系在一起，这赋予了他一个单单一个军阀未必会拥有的维度。是的。我的意思是，我认为有很多盎格鲁-撒克逊国王非常擅长在战争中杀人。而阿尔弗雷德在战争中杀人非常非常擅长。而且在需要的时候，他完全有能力表现得非常残酷。你知道，认为他是一个维多利亚绅士的观点是不真实的。
You know, you don't become a successful warlord without being able to be very, very brutal. But I think where Alfred is exceptional, and, you know, the reason why it's legitimate to think of him as great, if you believe in that kind of concept of great, is he seems to have had a real and authentic kind of originality of mind and a kind of breadth of vision that enables him to see what you do with your military victories. And Alfred seems to have understood that you can't really have a strong army and therefore a strong kingdom that is capable of keeping enemies at bay without also having the apparatus of learning. So monasteries where monks and nuns are going and towns that are prosperous and able to generate revenue. So he understands that learning and wealth are basically
你知道，如果不具备非常非常残酷的能力，你是成不了一个成功的军阀的。但我认为阿尔弗雷德的卓越之处在于，你知道，为什么认为他伟大是合理的（如果你相信那种伟大概念的话），在于他似乎拥有真正且真实的思想独创性和一种广阔的视野，这使他能够明白如何利用你的军事胜利。阿尔弗雷德似乎明白，如果没有学习的机器，你就不可能真正拥有能够将敌人拒之门外的强大军队，进而拥有强大的王国。因此，需要有僧侣和修女前往的修道院，以及繁荣并能够创造收入的城镇。所以他明白学习和财富基本上是
the key to being a great military leader and that they're a kind of single package. And he seems to have understood that better than any other king in early medieval England. And I wonder whether one of the reasons why he gets that sense is firstly, that he's been to the continent. We've talked about that. But also when he comes back to England, it's to a land that is under massive strain and where actually the worldly possessions of his own family and certainly of other royal families are starting to come under strain because they're being pillaged by invaders. And that infrastructure of learning that had sustained Christian civilization in England for centuries is likewise starting to crumble. And this is why Alfred doesn't have the chance to learn in the way that he would have wanted to. And all you can do is learn by heart because the apparatus of teaching is no longer there. And of course, the reason why both learning and prosperity are coming under attack during Alfred's childhood is because he is coming of age in a
成为伟大军事领袖的关键，它们是一个整体的组合包。他似乎比早期中世纪英格兰的任何其他国王都更好地理解这一点。我想知道他为什么会有这种感觉，原因之一首先是他去过欧洲大陆。我们已经讨论过这一点。但也是因为当他回到英格兰时，这片土地正承受着巨大的压力，他自己家族的世俗财产，当然还有其他王室家族的世俗财产，实际上正开始承受压力，因为它们遭到入侵者的掠夺。几个世纪以来一直维持着英格兰基督教文明的学习基础设施也同样开始瓦解。这就是为什么阿尔弗雷德没有获得他原本想要的学习机会的原因。而你所能做的只有死记硬背，因为教学机器已经不复存在了。当然，学习和繁荣在阿尔弗雷德童年时期之所以遭到攻击，是因为他正处于一个
period of devastating evasion by the Vikings. That's a great segue, Tom. Perfect segue. I think we should take a break and we should return after the break with the Vikings and Alfred's struggles against the Vikings. See you in a minute. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
维京人毁灭性入侵的时期。这是一个很好的过渡，汤姆。完美的过渡。我想我们应该休息一下，休息后我们将带着维京人和阿尔弗雷德与维京人的斗争回归。一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一点八卦的地方，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、额外分集以及提前获得现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. now this episode of the rest is history is sponsored by our friends at unheard the online magazine that encourages independent thinking and as it happens i've just written an article for unheard all about the vikings talking about their reputation today and the way in which we should tell their stories to children. So when I was writing my book, there were lots of gory bits. And to forestall any talk of the dreaded sensitivity readers, I read bits to children, school groups, and so on. The children generally loved them, except there was one little girl I always remember who sort of frowned and shook her head. And afterwards, she came up to me, and she looked very serious, and she's still
那是 therestisentertainment.com。现在，本期《剩下的就是历史》由我们的朋友 UnHerd 赞助，这是一个鼓励独立思考的在线杂志，恰好我刚刚为 UnHerd 写了一篇文章，全关于维京人，讨论他们今天的声誉以及我们应该如何向儿童讲述他们的故事。所以当我写书时，里面有很多血腥的片段。为了消除对可怕的敏感度审读员的任何谈论，我向儿童、学校团体等朗读了片段。孩子们通常很喜欢它们，除了我一直记得的一个小女孩，她皱着眉头摇了摇头。后来，她向我走来，看起来非常严肃，而且她还在
shaking her head. And I said, what's the trouble? And she said, there wasn't enough beheading. If you're rewriting it, put in more deaths, please. So the future of the British nation is clearly in great hands. Now, if you want to read more from UnHerd, there is a new special offer. And it's been running since Bonfire Night for listeners to The Rest is History. So you can enjoy UnHerd every day. It's only a pound for three months, one pound, and it runs this week only, the offer. So normally, UnHerd would cost you a pound a week,
摇着头。我说，有什么问题吗？她说，砍头还不够多。如果你要重写，请加入更多的死亡。所以英国未来的国家显然掌握在伟大的手中。现在，如果你想阅读更多来自 UnHerd 的内容，有一个新的特别优惠。自篝火之夜以来，它一直为《剩下的就是历史》的听众举办。所以你可以每天享受 UnHerd。只需一英镑三个月，一英镑，而且这个优惠仅本周有效。通常情况下，UnHerd 会让你花费一英镑一周，
but this is just a pound for three months. So go to unheard.com slash rest. That's unheard.com slash rest to claim your subscription now. The raiders charged up the beaches of Lindisfarne like a storm from the depths of hell. The first monk they met on the path leading up from the shore, they hacked to the ground without a word, an axe splintering his skull in a moment. Then they raced on up the slope, their swords eager for slaughter. More monks came towards them, their hands raised to beg for mercy. The Vikings cut them down where they stood. Blood splattered over the turf. Now they were into the monastery, crashing through the doors, roaring and howling with diabolical rage.
但这只需一英镑三个月。所以请访问 unheard.com slash rest。那是 unheard.com slash rest，立即领取您的订阅。袭击者像来自地狱深处的风暴一样冲上林迪isfarne的海滩。他们在从海岸延伸的小路上遇到的第一个僧侣，二话没说就把他砍倒在地上，一把斧头在一瞬间劈裂了他的头骨。然后他们继续冲上山坡，他们的宝剑渴望屠杀。更多的僧侣向他们走来，双手高举乞求怜悯。维京人在他们站立的地方将他们砍倒。鲜血洒在草皮上。现在他们进入了修道院，撞开大门，带着恶魔般的愤怒咆哮和尖叫。
They pulled down the crosses and smashed open the tombs. They piled up the holy vessels and stamped on the relics. They tore off the altar cloth, ripped up the Bibles, and dragged out the desks. And all the time, Tom, they were laughing, a chorus of cruel and savage joy. So, the rotters. That is the raid on Lindisfarne in the year 793.
他们拉倒十字架，砸开坟墓。他们堆起圣器，踩踏圣物。他们撕下祭坛布，撕毁圣经，拖出书桌。而且一直以来，汤姆，他们都在笑，这是一组合唱，充满了残酷和野蛮的喜悦。所以，这些混蛋。那是公元 793 年对林迪斯法恩的袭击。
Often taken, in most sort of general histories of the Vikings, that's always taken as the kickoff, you know, the most exciting moment when they explode into the pages of history. So that was obviously a reading from a wonderful new children's book called Fury of the Vikings by myself. Yeah, very good. But Tom, actually, that's not the first time they had pitched up. No.
在大多数关于维京人的通史中，这通常被认为是开球，你知道的，当他们闯入历史页面时最令人兴奋的时刻。所以这显然是对我写的一本名为《维京人的愤怒》的精彩新儿童书的朗读。是的，非常好。但汤姆，实际上，这不是他们第一次露面。不。
So as early as kind of the mid-8th century, so kind of 750, 753, you're getting chroniclers in the Isle of Thanet describing Danish raiders as a kind of um a kind of disease that induces madness and death yeah um and they the vikings seem to have um been raiding the southern coast of england they disgraced themselves in dorset didn't they do four years earlier yes the isle of portland yeah and they turn up and the a local reeve a kind of royal official thinks that they've well that they're the peaceable traders of 1960s historiography exactly come and talk to me about multiculturalism in your lovely jewelry there goes his head um and and you would expect of course you know the channel is the easiest for
早在8世纪中期左右，也就是大约 750 年、753 年，你就会发现泰尼岛的编年史家将丹麦袭击者描述为一种会引发疯狂和死亡的疾病。是的，呃，维京人似乎在袭击英格兰南部海岸，他们在多塞特郡让自己名誉扫地，不是吗，就在四年之前？是的，波特兰岛，是的。他们出现了，一个当地的郡长——某种皇家官员，认为他们是1960年代历史学中爱好和平的商人。完全正确，来跟我谈谈你那可爱首饰里的多元文化主义吧。他的脑袋掉了下来。而且，你会预料到，当然（你知道的，海峡是船只最容易到达的地方，你知道的，你顺着北海海岸线的方向走）。所以肯特郡和英格兰南海岸在这一时期开始遭到袭击并不令人意外。但林迪斯法恩对所有人来说都是一个震惊，因为当然，它是圣卡斯伯特的神社，非常是节目的朋友。所以它确实拥有一个，我敢说，真正神圣的地方，汤姆。它超越了神圣，多米尼克。在英国人的心中。它确实如此。
ships to to get to you know you follow the line line of the North Sea coast. So it's not surprising that Kent and the South Coast of England are starting to be raided through this period. But Lindisfarne is a shock to everyone because of course, it's the Shrine of St. Cuthbert, very much a friend of the show. So it has a genuinely, dare I say, sacral place, Tom. It's beyond sacral, Dominic. In the hearts of Englishmen. It certainly does.
而且正如我们将看到的，卡斯伯特在非洲有着巨大的影响力。他的确如此，是的。所以维京人，我的意思是，很明显他们是来自现在的丹麦、我想还有挪威、在某种程度上还有瑞典的袭击者和商人，不过我认为瑞典人可能更多是向东而不是向西。但他们一直以来，几乎可以肯定的是，他们长期以来一直在进行贸易。北海一直是一个湖泊。
And as we will see, Cuthbert has a great hold on Africa. He does indeed, yeah. So the Vikings, I mean, obviously they are raiders and traders from what are now Denmark, I suppose Norway, to some extent Sweden, though. I think the Swedes are probably going east rather than west. But they have always, almost certainly, they've been coming for a long time to trade. The North Sea has been a lake.
是的，一个湖泊。但似乎发生的事情，不是吗，在大约8世纪中期，维京人变成了，我们所说的维京人，北欧人变得更大胆了，他们变得更具侵略性了，有更多东西供他们偷窃了。是的，所以林迪斯法恩非常富裕，是的，显然一旦他们袭击了林迪斯法恩并掠夺了它，这个消息就会传开，从那时起，本质上，英格兰所有财富的据点，修道院、皇家中心等等，都成了待宰的羔羊。而且值得讨论一下，为什么要费心去英格兰？答案是
Yeah, a lake. But what seems to have happened, doesn't it, in the sort of mid-eighth century is that the Vikings become, what we call the Vikings, the norsemen become emboldened they become more aggressive there's more stuff for them to steal yeah so so lindisfarne is very rich yeah and obviously once they've descended on lindisfarne purloined it the news of that gets around and from from that point on, essentially, all the strongholds of wealth in England, monasteries, royal centres, whatever, are kind of sitting ducks. And it's worth sort of saying, I think, why bother going to England? The answer is that
英格兰非常富裕。英格兰富裕、定居而且稳定。它拥有所有这些农田，坦率地说，他们在挪威没有这些。是的，一开始，他们不一定在定居。而且问题还在于，有了他们的船只，他们可以顺流而上。所以每一条主要河流都像是一把直刺英格兰心脏的匕首
England is very rich. England is rich and settled and stable. It has all this farmland, which frankly, they don't have in Norway. Yeah, to begin with, they're not settling necessarily. And the thing also is that with their ships, they can kind of glide up rivers. So every major river is like a kind of dagger pointed at the vitals of England
他们可以顺流而上，抓起东西就走。升级的标志是他们开始过冬，所以大约是 850 年，对吧？所以在 850 年，他们在泰尼岛过冬，这是《1066年及所有那类事》中的经典笑话，所有的入侵都始于泰尼岛，所以那是肯特郡的最角落。所以这不仅仅是他们要袭击你的城镇，他们要袭击你的修道院然后消失，这意味着他们要来并留下来。他们开始思考，是的，我们要在那里扎根过冬，从长远来看，试着夺取土地和整个王国。
and they can glide up and just grab stuff and then go. The mark of the escalation is when they start to overwinter so that's about 850 isn't it so 850 they winter on the isle of thanet which is the kind of running joke in 1066 and all that that all invasions begin in the isle of thanet so that's the very corner of kent so it's not just they're going to hit your town they're going to hit your monastery and then disappear this is they're coming and they're staying they're starting to think yeah we'll put down roots here over winter and we'll, in the long run, try and grab land and entire kingdoms.
他们的确如此
Yeah. And they seem, so the Isle of Thanet in Kent, Wessex is vulnerable. After they've overwintered there, they strike into Wessex and they get annihilated. A great battle in Surrey. That's such an old thing to say, a great battle in Surrey on the Gulf Coast. But it was described as the greatest slaughter on a heathen army that we ever heard of until this present day. And that's being written in the time of Alfred. So that's even by comparison with Alfred's victories. So I think one of the reasons why
肯特的坦尼特岛，威塞克斯是脆弱的。在他们那里过冬后，他们向威塞克斯发起进攻，结果被彻底消灭。萨里发生了一场大战。在海湾海岸的萨里打一场大战，这种说法听起来太古老了。但它被描述为我们至今所听闻的对异教徒军队的最大屠杀。而且这是在阿尔弗雷德时代被记录下来的。所以，甚至与阿尔弗雷德的胜利相比也是如此。因此我认为，其中一个原因
Wessex comes under less strain than the other kingdoms despite the fact that in a way it's absolutely in the path of all these fleets coming over the north sea is that they do put up a good showing and that the memory of this this great slaughter um at a place called aclaia is remembered by the vikings and so they go after other softer targets yeah i mean there's a sense isn't there sometimes in the sort of popular imagination of the Anglo-Saxons, you definitely see this in TV series, that the Anglo-Saxons are sort of weedy,
威塞克斯承受的压力比其他王国要小，尽管从某种程度上说它完全位于所有这些跨越北海的舰队的必经之路上，原因在于他们表现得非常出色，而且维京人在一个叫做阿克莱亚的地方遭受惨败的记忆被他们铭记在心，因此他们去寻找其他更容易下手的目标。是的，我是说，在对盎格鲁-撒克逊人的流行想象中，有时确实有一种感觉——你在电视剧里绝对能看到这一点——即盎格鲁-撒克逊人有点像弱不禁风的、
foppish monks, and the Vikings are terribly fierce, brilliant fighters. But the Vikings at first are not terribly good at pitched battles because they're raiding parties, they're not armies. And they don't do sieges particularly,
矫揉造作的修士，而维京人则异常凶猛、是出色的战士。但维京人起初并不擅长阵地战，因为他们是突袭队伍，而不是正规军队。而且他们特别不擅长围城战，
they're not very good at sieges at first. So the Anglo-Saxons are not... The Anglo-Saxons are not weedy no exactly you know the anglo-saxons are very very keen on fighting they're very good at fighting but they are not suited to the kind of warfare that the vikings bring because as we said in the first part they um you know you have to raise armies from the shires you have to have meeting points. So the passage we opened with Egbert's Stone, set up by Egbert, Alfred's grandfather, this is a meeting point. But if you've got a Viking ship gliding up the river
他们起初很不擅长围城。所以盎格鲁-撒克逊人并不是……盎格鲁-撒克逊人并不是弱不禁风的，完全没错，你知道的，盎格鲁-撒克逊人非常热衷于战斗，他们非常擅长战斗，但他们并不适合维京人带来的那种战争，因为正如我们在第一部分中所说的那样，嗯，你知道的，你必须从各个郡征召军队，你必须有集合点。所以我们开篇提到的埃格伯特之石，由阿尔弗雷德的祖父埃格伯特建立，这就是一个集合点。但是，如果你有一艘维京战船顺流滑行而来，
and a great fat monastery, they're just going to grab it and hair off before the local troops can be summoned from all the various corners. It's that point you made about not fighting by the rules. Yeah. The Vikings don't follow the rules. But obviously, the more treasure you get, the richer you become, the more troops you can attract,
还有一个肥沃的大修道院，他们就会直接抢劫它，并在当地军队从各个角落被召集起来之前逃之夭夭。这就是你所说的“不按规矩出牌”这一点。是的。维京人确实不按规矩办事。但显然，你得到的财宝越多，你变得越富有，你能吸引的军队就越多，
the larger and larger you become. And this is the problem. It just becomes, you know, it's a kind of escalating danger. And it's happening so quickly that the apparatus of these Anglo-Saxon kingdoms is inadequate to cope with it. But I don't think it's, you know, there's no sense that any of the Anglo-Saxon kingdoms is inadequate to cope with it. But I don't think it's, you know, there's no sense that any of the Anglo-Saxon kings are weedy. But the Anglo-Saxon, so interestingly, the one that they attack most successfully first, which is Northumbria, is divided. So it's always the way when you're divided that attracts outsiders. And I think it's when, I mean, that's Alfred's genius in a way, is that he privileges, he prioritises the idea of unity
你的规模就会越来越大。这就是问题所在。它只是变成了一种不断升级的危险。而且这种情况发生得如此之快，以至于这些盎格鲁-撒克逊王国的国家机器根本无力应对。但我不认为，你知道的，没有任何迹象表明任何一个盎格鲁-撒克逊王国无力应对它。我不认为，你知道的，没有任何迹象表明任何一个盎格鲁-撒克逊国王是软弱的。但是盎格鲁-撒克逊人，有趣的是，他们最先成功攻击的那个王国——诺森布里亚，是分裂的。所以当你分裂时，总是会吸引外来者。而我认为，这就是阿尔弗雷德的过人之处，他赋予了特权，他优先考虑了统一的理念
and his idea of sort of Englishness, which is sort of Bernard Cornwell fantasy Alfred. I mean, that kind of makes sense, that that's exactly the way that you would fight off these raiders who are sort of striking that warning. Yeah, so by 865, you've had these raiders who are sort of striking their warning yeah so so by uh by 865 um you've had
以及他那关于英式身份的理念，这有点像是伯纳德·康威尔笔下的幻想阿尔弗雷德。我的意思是，这在某种程度上说得通，这正是你用来击退这些发出警告的袭击者的正确方式。是的，所以到865年，你们已经遭到了这些袭击者的袭击，他们发出警告，是的，所以到865年，嗯，你们已经经历了
these raiders coming for decades and they're starting to accumulate more and more people you get what in old english is called the mickle heaven hera uh a vast heathen vast pagan army and um there's a great book called viking england by thomas williams who who who who defines a hera and our army as actually being a large group of thieves working together which i think is maybe a slightly more accurate um description of it but so they overwinter in east anglia where there's a king edmund who basically buys them off gives them a load of horses and they go galloping off up Ermine Street, the old Roman road that leads to York.
这些持续了数十年的袭击，他们开始聚集越来越多的人，这就是古英语中所说的“mickle heathen hera”（庞大的异教徒军队）——一支庞大的异教徒军队，嗯，有一本由托马斯·威廉姆斯写的非常棒的书叫《维京英格兰》，他将“hera”和军队定义为实际上是一群协同作案的大盗，我认为这或许是一个稍微更准确的描述。但是，他们是在东盎格利亚过冬的，那里有一个国王埃德蒙，他基本上花钱打发了他们，给了他们一大批马，然后他们骑着马沿着埃尔明街（Ermine Street）飞奔而去，那是通往约克的古罗马道路。
And they just ride straight into York because the Northumbering Kings have no idea. Well, there's two Northumbering Kings who've fallen out with each other, aren't there? Aella and Osbert. And Aella, ultimately, who meets this famous fate. So I was saying in the first half, giving talks to schoolchildren about the vikings they
他们直接骑马冲进了约克，因为诺森布里亚的国王们毫无防备。好吧，有两个诺森布里亚国王闹翻了，不是吗？埃拉和奥斯伯特。而埃拉，最终迎来了这个著名的结局。所以我刚才在前半部分说过，当给学童们做关于维京人的讲座时，他们
always ask the same kind of four or five questions so one of them is horned helmets obviously yeah but another one is a boy and it'll always be a boy a very sort of a boy with death in his eyes did they do the blood eagle because aella is the person who supposedly falls victim to this so there's a the guy who's meant to have done it, one of the leaders of the great heathen army, has the absolutely splendid name of Ivar the Boneless. Yeah. And nobody knows.
总是会问同样的大约四五个问题，其中一个显然是关于有角的头盔，是的，但另一个是关于一个男孩——而且总是一个男孩，一个眼神中透着死气的男孩——他们做过“血鹰”仪式吗？因为埃拉据说就是这个仪式的受害者。所以，有一个据说是这样做的家伙，伟大异教徒军队的领袖之一，有一个绝对拉风的名字叫“无骨人伊瓦尔”。是的。而且没有人知道。
But his brothers are always as good, aren't they? There's Halfdan, Halfdan Whiteshirt. And Hubba. Yeah, Hubba. I think Hubba. Hubba is funnier. But I either the boneless he may have had some kind of we don't know some historians think he may have had brittle bone disease or he may have had i mean who knows spina bifida or or is it a mistranslation it's so suffused with
但他的兄弟们也同样厉害，不是吗？有哈夫丹，白衫哈夫丹。还有胡巴。是的，胡巴。我认为胡巴。胡巴更有趣。但无骨人伊瓦尔，他可能患有某种我们不知道的疾病，一些历史学家认为他可能患有成骨不全症（脆骨病），或者他可能患有——谁知道呢——脊柱裂，或者这是一个翻译错误？这里面充满了
myth isn't it it is because they're meant to be the sons of um uh ragnar lothbrok ragnar hairpants who is killed a dragon wearing trousers which where yeah where he's rolled in snow and made kind of frozen all the fur and then the serpent wraps itself around him and exactly and dies that's basically the kind of the level of probability that we're well hold on tom in my in my version of the story in the children's book this absolutely absolutely happened. The Ragnar is real. But also there's, I mean, there's a medieval epic, and this is centuries after it, that says that Ragnar gets chucked into a pit of snakes by Aella. By Aella, yeah. Anyone who's seen the Kirk Douglas film, The Vikings, this is one of the key plot motors.
神话，不是吗？确实如此，因为他们被认为是……嗯，拉格纳·洛德布罗克的儿子，拉格纳·“毛裤”拉格纳，他穿着裤子杀死了一条巨龙。在哪里？哦，他在雪地里打滚，让所有的皮毛都冻成冰，然后那条大蛇盘绕在他身上，然后——没错——就死掉了。这基本上就是我们故事的可信度水平。等等，汤姆，在我的故事版本里——在儿童书里——这绝对、绝对发生过。拉格纳是真实的。但同时，有一部中世纪史诗（这比当时晚了好几个世纪），上面说拉格纳被埃拉扔进了一个蛇坑。被埃拉，是的。任何看过柯克·道格拉斯主演的电影《维京人》的人都会知道，这是核心情节的推动力之一。
And so this, I think, what is it? 13th century, 12th century, that story? Yeah. They want revenge on Aella, don't they? So they capture Aella. He's tried to get York back. He and all the lads have piled in. They get cornered. They get captured. And supposedly, according to a 13th century epic ivor and his brothers had the eagle cut into ella's back then all his ribs severed from the backbone with the sword so that his lungs were pulled out and this is the blood eagle and it looks like you know he's got these kind of bloody wings sadly tom this may not be true indeed because a century earlier a danish writer with the brilliant name of saxo grammaticmaticus says that the eagle is actually carved into Aela's back and they then rub salt into it, don't they?
所以这个故事，我想是什么时候？13世纪，12世纪？是的。他们想向埃拉报复，对吧？所以他们抓住了埃拉。他曾试图夺回约克。他和所有小伙子们都冲了进去。他们被逼入绝境。他们被俘虏了。据13世纪的一部史诗记载，伊瓦尔和他的兄弟们在埃拉的背上刻下了鹰的形状，然后用剑把他的所有肋骨从脊椎上切断，这样他的肺就被拉了出来，这就是“血鹰”仪式，看起来就像他长着带血的翅膀一样。遗憾的是，汤姆，这可能不是真的。确实，因为在一个世纪前，一个名叫萨克索·格拉玛蒂库斯（Saxo Grammaticus）的才华横溢的丹麦作家说，鹰实际上是被刻在埃拉的背上的，然后他们把盐揉进伤口里，对吧？
Which is in its way, I mean, it's better, but it's still probably quite unpleasant. the court of knut yeah um so the the danish king who becomes king yeah of waves fame uh where again they say that um you know this this eagle is is inscribed onto the back of the king or it could conceivably mean that um either has an eagle tear at alice yes so he has a kind of pet eagle that rips him out but either way tom you've got a bloke with no bones doing something eagle related something absolutely unspeakable and equal relations to somebody else while his brothers are looking on and cackling through their beards i mean great scenes great great stuff great stuff hubba roaring with laughter uh yeah so it's all it's all very very frightening um and obviously this isn't good news for the northumbrians um because they uh you know they've lost their kings they get a a tame puppet king a
这从某种程度上来说——虽然更好一点，但可能还是相当令人不快。克努特的宫廷，是的，嗯，也就是那个成为国王的丹麦国王，是的，凭借波浪成名的那个故事，在那里他们又说，嗯，这只鹰被刻在了国王的背上，或者它也可以合理地理解为伊瓦尔让一只鹰去撕扯埃拉，是的，所以他有一种宠物鹰把他撕碎了。但不管怎样，汤姆，你有一个没有骨头的家伙在做一些与鹰有关的事情，对某人做着绝对惨绝人寰且与鹰有关的事情，而他的兄弟们则在一旁看着，透过胡子格格大笑。我的意思是，精彩的场面，太棒了，太棒了，胡巴放声大笑——是的，所以这一切都非常非常可怕——显然这对诺森布里亚人来说不是什么好消息，因为他们失去了国王，他们被安插了一个驯服的傀儡国王，一个
kind of quizzling put over them uh and then the um they go off and invade mercia and this is where alfred enters the story as a warrior because the first known example of him riding to war is to go is to join the mercians and alfred's wife is a mercian yes uh her name is um ailswith exactly yes um and they go off to nottingham where the vikings have have kind of built themselves a fort and they get rebuffed they can't attack it and they don't know what to do again it's because the vikings aren't playing by rules under the terms of traditional sporting you know marcus queensberry rules yeah i think supposed to come out and have a fight and they don't so um it's it's all a little bit inglorious
类似于瑟维林（傀儡）一样的统治者强加在他们头上，然后他们出发去入侵麦西亚，阿尔弗雷德正是在这里作为一名战士登上了历史舞台，因为他骑马参战的第一个已知记录就是去加入麦西亚人，而且阿尔弗雷德的妻子是麦西亚人，是的，她的名字叫埃尔斯威斯，完全正确，是的，他们前往诺丁汉，维京人在那里建立了一个堡垒，但他们被击退了，无法对其发起攻击，而且他们不知道该怎么办。同样，这是因为维京人没有按照规矩出牌，在传统的体育规则、你知道的，马奎斯·奥奎斯雷规则下，是的，我想他们应该出来打一架，但他们没有，所以这一切都有点不够光彩。
there so the anglo-saxon chronicle is this brilliant there occurred no serious fighting there so it's a score draw right yeah um and it may be telling that this is when alfred this is the same year that alfred marries um elswithans. So there's clearly a sense, I think, that the West Saxons and the Mercians are aware that this is a very grievous threat, and they need to completely bury their difference. Well, after this, there's another example of Viking poor behaviour,
所以盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史里有这样一段精彩的记录：那里没有发生认真的战斗。所以这是一个平局，对吧？是的，这可能说明，这就是阿尔弗雷德……这正是阿尔弗雷德娶埃尔斯威斯的同一年。因此，显然有一种感觉，我认为，西撒克逊人和麦西亚人都意识到这是一个非常严重的威胁，他们需要彻底捐弃前嫌。好吧，在这之后，维京人的不良行为又添了一例，
Tom. Very. Because they, because you, some people may remember that we said, you'd said they were given a load of horses by Edmund, the king of east anglia when they arrived he'd bought them off they then pitch up back in east anglia and they say actually we'll have your kingdom we'll have a lot please yeah we'll have a lot um edmund resists doesn't he he says you know i'm not gonna we don't really know yeah but i mean all we're told is all we're
汤姆。非常严重。因为他们，因为你，有些人可能还记得我们说过，你曾说过当他们到达时，东盎格利亚国王埃德蒙给了他们一大批马，他买通了他们。后来他们又回到了东盎格利亚，他们说：“其实，我们要占领你们的王国，我们要一块地盘，请吧。”是的，“我们要一块地盘”。埃德蒙进行了抵抗，不是吗？他说：“你知道的，我不会——”我们其实并不知道，是的。但我的意思是，我们被告知的全部内容是，我们
told is is that he dies that there's a battle and he dies. But later on, it was said they captured him. They tie him up and they fire arrows at him so that he's prickly like a hedgehog. Yeah. Which I think is a lovely image. And then eventually, supposedly they're firing arrows at him and he's just there. He still doesn't die. Yeah, talking about Jesus. He's just shouting, talking about Jesus the whole time.
所被告知的全部内容就是他死了，爆发了一场战斗，他死了。但后来，据说他们抓住了他。他们把他绑起来，向他发射箭矢，让他像刺猬一样长满尖刺。是的。我认为这是一个可爱的画面。然后最终，据说他们向他发射箭矢，他就站在那里。他竟然还没死。是的，还在谈论耶稣。他只是在大喊，一直在谈论耶稣。
They fire arrows. He won't shut up. So eventually they cut his head off. Isn't that right? They cut his head off and throw it into the woods. They chuck it into a bramble patch in the middle of a wood. And then they gallop off, kind of roaring with laughter as you would with such thing. And then subsequently, a peasant is walking through the wood and he hears this voice going, Hick, Hick, Hick. And he's not drunk because Hick means is Latin for here. Yeah. And he goes over and there is King Edmund's head being guarded by a giant wolf.
他们射箭。他就是不肯闭嘴。所以最后他们砍掉了他的头。不是吗？他们砍下他的头，扔进了树林里。他们把它扔进了树林中央的一处荆棘丛中。然后他们策马离去，伴随着你面对这种事情时会有的狂笑。随后，一个农民穿过树林，他听到一个声音在喊：“Hick, Hick, Hick”。他并没有喝醉，因为“Hick”在拉丁语里是“这里”的意思。是的。他走过去，发现埃德蒙国王的头正由一只巨狼守护着。
Fantastic stuff. And I don't know if you saw on Twitter over Halloween, there was an excellent, somebody had dressed up as a wolf with St. Edmund's head as a halloween costume really yeah it was excellent costume that is a good costume and of course that tom is the origin of bury saint edmunds the place isn't it it is although it's not about the burying no saint edmunds obviously because bury is the burr which will come to in the course of town so if you if you have been moved by this story get yourself down to edury St Edmunds. Well, so Francis Young, who we had on the show talking about-
太棒了。我不知道你在万圣节的时候有没有刷到推特，有一个非常棒的人打扮成了一只狼，头上顶着圣埃德蒙的头作为万圣节服装。真的吗？是的，那是一套极好的服装。那确实是一套好服装。当然，汤姆，那就是伯里圣埃德蒙兹（Bury St Edmunds）这个地名的起源，不是吗？是的，尽管这与掩埋无关，不，圣埃德蒙兹显然是因为“bury”是“burh（堡垒）”，我们会在接下来的节目中讲到。所以，如果你被这个故事打动了，那就去一趟埃德里·圣埃德蒙兹（Edury St Edmunds）吧。那么，弗朗西斯·扬（Francis Young），我们曾邀请他上节目谈论——
The occult. The occult. Big, big fan of Edmund. And he is convinced that Edmund's tomb still lies under the tennis courts at Bury St Edmunds. Really? Which would be very exciting.
神秘学。神秘学。埃德蒙的超级大粉丝。他坚信埃德蒙的墓至今仍然埋在伯里圣埃德蒙兹的网球场下面。真的吗？那将是非常令人兴奋的。
He should do a Philippa Langley and try and dig up the tennis courts. I think he's gagging too. He's absolutely desperate to do that. But basically you're right that the death of Edmund gets kind of hyped up by a monk called Abo of Fleury
他应该效仿菲利帕·兰利（Philippa Langley），尝试去把网球场挖开。我想他急不可耐了。他绝对渴望这么做。但基本上你是对的，埃德蒙之死被一个名叫弗勒里的阿博（Abo of Fleury）的僧侣炒作了，
who's writing in the late 10th century. Who does, I mean, he's obviously aware that what he's writing is unlike, you know, there might be a bit of doubt about it because he's very keen to say, I heard it from this guy, who heard it from this guy, who heard it from this guy. But basically, he's casting him as being like Christ. This is his passion.
他是在10世纪末写作的。他显然知道他所写的内容可能并非……你知道的，可能会有一些疑问，因为他非常急于说明：“我是从这个人那里听说的，这个人又是从那个人那里听说的，那个人又是从另一个人那里听说的。”但基本上，他将他塑造得如同基督一般。这就是他的受难记。
And so Edmund becomes a very, very significant saint throughout the Middle Ages. Yeah, whether or not it's true, the fact of the matter is now that the Vikings, who decades before had just been pillagers they have taken northumbria they have taken east anglia they have reduced mercia to a kind of client state that they can crush a will yeah and suddenly wessex is really vulnerable it's just sitting there ripe for taking yeah well so it seems so 870 which is the year that edmund dies they they the vikings go off and attack um wessex and they attack reading yeah um and there uh they capture reading but they have a foraging party that gets wiped out by the local um the local elder man the local earl a man called athelwolf and this inspires um athelred who is alfred's elder brother
因此，在整个中世纪，埃德蒙成为一个非常、非常重要的圣徒。是的，不管这是真是假，事实是，几十年前还只是掠夺者的维京人，现在已经占领了诺森布里亚，占领了东盎格利亚，把麦西亚降格为一个他们可以随心所欲碾压的附庸国。是的，突然之间，威塞克斯变得极其脆弱，它就那样坐在那里，唾手可得。是的，好吧，情况似乎确实如此。870年，也就是埃德蒙去世的那一年，维京人出发去攻击威塞克斯，他们攻击了雷丁。是的，在那里他们占领了雷丁，但他们有一支搜寻食物的小分队被当地的长老、当地的伯爵——一个名叫埃塞尔沃尔夫（Aethelwulf）的人——彻底消灭了，这激发了阿尔弗雷德的哥哥埃塞尔雷德（Aethelred）
the fourth of of um of his brothers to have become king and the other three have basically all kind of you know they've been worn out by the challenge of leading wessex in this very troubled time um so he and alfred um go and try and recapture red, are defeated, are hurled back. Arthur Wolfe is killed. It looks like an absolute disaster. The West Saxons are kind of having to cross and recross the Thames to try and escape the Vikings. They're basically just fighting constant battles around the M4, aren't they? Exactly. Right around service stations along the M4.
他是他兄弟中第四个当上国王的，另外三个基本上都，你知道的，在这个多事之秋里，被领导威塞克斯的挑战给折磨得精疲力竭了。所以他和阿尔弗雷德去试图重新夺回雷德，结果被打败了，被击退了。阿尔弗雷德阵亡了。这看起来就像是一场绝对的灾难。西撒克逊人不得不一次次横渡泰晤士河来试图逃避维京人。他们基本上就是在M4公路周围进行不断的战斗，对吧？没错。就在M4公路沿线的服务区周围。
But they do win a great victory um so shortly after this in early january 871 they win a great victory um fighting around a single thorn tree so it comes really called ash down yes um and alfred it is said takes the lead in this he charges like a wild boar up a hill well this is basically downplays alfred's brother yeah and brother and says he was too busy praying. He was late for the battle because he was praying. Alfred's roaring and charging into battle and all this stuff. Yeah, exactly. Not a boring person, but a wild, aggressive pig.
但他们确实赢得了伟大的胜利，就在这之后不久，在871年1月上旬，他们赢得了伟大的胜利，围绕着一棵孤零零的荆棘树作战，所以它真的被称为阿什当，是的。而且据说阿尔弗雷德在这场战斗中带头，他像一头野猪一样冲上山坡。嗯，这基本上贬低了阿尔弗雷德的兄弟，是的，兄弟，并说他太忙于祈祷了。他因为祈祷而迟到了战斗。阿尔弗雷德在咆哮着冲入战斗以及所有这些。是的，绝对的。不是一个无聊的人，而是一头狂野、好斗的猪。
So in 871, Atharad dies, doesn't he? Yeah. So Alfred becomes king. And Atharad has sons. He has two boys. But there's no question of them succeeding. No. Because, you know, this is…
所以在871年，埃塞尔雷德死了，对吧？是的。所以阿尔弗雷德成为了国王。而埃塞尔雷德有儿子。他有两个男孩。但根本没有让他们继承王位的问题。没有。因为，你知道，这……
It'd be bonkers in the current conditions. It would. Yeah. It would. Not least because there's another Viking force now, isn't there? So, there's a second Viking horde that has sailed up the Thames called the Great Summer Army. And that's led by a man called Guthrum. So, Guthrum is basically… we know so little about Guthrum.
在当前的情况下，那太疯狂了。确实是的。绝对是。不仅因为现在有另一支维京军队，对吧？所以，有第二支维京大军顺着泰晤士河航行而来，被称为伟大夏季军。这支军队由一个叫古斯伦的人领导。所以，古斯伦基本上……我们对古斯伦知之甚少。
It's so disappointing when you look at the sources. Great name, though. Because in all the kind of tales and legends, Guthrum is the antagonist par excellence, isn't he? You sort of – I think it's probably the Lady Bird book or something that I read when I was about 10. Guthrum was a massive man, you know, 10 feet tall, really wide, massive beard. Horns on his helmet.
当你查看历史资料时，这太让人失望了。不过名字很好听。因为在所有的传说和故事中，古斯伦都是最典型的反派，对吧？你有点——我想大概是我十岁左右读的Lady Bird童书或者别的什么。古斯伦是个大块头，你知道的，有10英尺高，非常宽阔，有着巨大的胡子。头盔上有角。
Horn, absolutely the horn, you know, multiple horns on his helmet, tattooed, you know, just a figure of just a brilliant antagonist. And he's going to be the person whose destiny is linked with alfred yeah yes and and almost straight away alfred alfred is you know the moment he's become king he's you know he's desperately trying to fight the vikings off so the vikings defeat him at wilton so yeah the place very near where i grew up um and alfred buys them off but you you know you know that they're going to be back and the the only reason really that they're not launching a full-blown invasion of Wessex is because they're now starting to move in on Mercia. They start overwintering in Mercia, huge great camps.
角，绝对是角，你知道的，头盔上有好几个角，有纹身，你知道的，简直就是一个绝佳的反派形象。而他将成为那个命运与阿尔弗雷德紧密相连的人，是的，而且几乎立刻，阿尔弗雷德，你知道他一当上国王，就拼命地试图把维京人打退，所以维京人在威尔顿击败了他，嗯，就在我长大的地方附近，而且阿尔弗雷德花钱把他们打发走了，但你知道他们会回来的，他们之所以没有对威塞克斯发动全面入侵，仅仅是因为他们现在开始向麦西亚推进。他们开始在麦西亚过冬，建立巨大的营地。
The archaeologist is really interesting. They say they found evidence basically that thousands of people were staying here. And you know the one at Repton? Oh, yes. There's a famous tomb, isn't there? Yes. So Repton, it was an acropolis for the Mercian kings,
考古学家非常有趣。他们说他们找到了证据，基本上有数千人留在这里。你知道雷普顿那个吗？哦，是的。有一个著名的陵墓，对吧？是的。所以雷普顿，它是麦西亚国王的卫城，
kind of a crypt where the Mercian kings were buried. So very, very, dare I say, sacral. Very, very significant. An emblem of Mercian royal power and status. And so the Vikings go and build a massive great camp there, utter humiliation. And they found an incredible grave there where a boar tusk had been placed
可以说是麦西亚国王安葬的地穴。所以非常非常，我敢说，神圣。非常非常重要。麦西亚王权和地位的象征。所以维京人在那里建立了一个巨大的营地，这是极大的耻辱。他们在那里发现了一个令人难以置信的坟墓，里面放置了一根野猪獠牙
where the genitals would have been. So presumably this guy had been castrated, disemboweled in battle and round his neck. He wore the hammer of Thor. Well, some people think he could have been either the boneless tom yes so i mean wouldn't that be a nice twist and maybe that's what the bonelessness meant comes from yeah so just what you say about the camps now that actually makes us think slightly
放在生殖器的位置。所以据推测这个人被阉割了，在战斗中被剖腹，并且他的脖子上。他戴着雷神的锤子。嗯，有些人认为他可能是那个无骨者汤姆，是的，所以我的意思是，这难道不是一个很好的转折吗，也许这就是无骨的意思的来源，是的，所以正如你刚才所说的关于营地的事，这实际上让我们产生了一点
differently perhaps about that viking horde because the viking horde is not just blokes with beards and non-horned helmets. There's almost certainly women and children with them and camp followers. And blacksmiths making swords and all kinds of stuff. So when you read some of the descriptions by modern historians of these Viking hordes and armies, they will say, you know what? If you'd actually seen them, it's a combination of a huge group of lads kind of tooled up for battle but it's also got the slight atmosphere maybe and this sounds a bit bonkers kind of slightly rock festival atmosphere in the background yeah i mean a very violent one very violent one very muddy people in tents though there probably would have been music there would have been a lot of drinking um a combination
对那支维京大军产生不同的看法，因为维京大军不仅仅是留着胡子、戴着没有角的头盔的汉子。其中几乎肯定有妇女、儿童和随军家属。还有打造剑的铁匠以及各种各样的人。所以当你阅读现代历史学家对这些维京 horde 和军队的一些描述时，他们会说，你知道吗？如果你真的亲眼见过他们，那是一大群全副武装准备战斗的小伙子的结合体，但它同时也带有一点点氛围，听起来可能有点疯狂，有点像背景里的摇滚音乐节氛围，是的，我是说一个非常暴力的，非常暴力的，满身泥泞的人住在帐篷里，尽管那里可能是有音乐的，会有很多饮酒，结合了
yeah a combination of a refugee camp a rock festival you know that's a stag do that's gone horribly wrong i mean probably not a good place to be a local woman or indeed a monk or indeed probably anyone um unless you're a massive viking lad yeah which case is obviously you know it's brilliant. And of course there are, you know, this is the plot of, of the Bernard Corwell novels is that English speaking angles or Saxons can
是的，难民营和摇滚音乐节的结合体，你知道，那是一个糟糕透顶的单身派对，我的意思是，作为一个当地妇女，或者一个修士，或者可能任何人，这可能都不是一个好地方，除非你是一个巨大的维京小伙子，是的，在这种情况下，很明显（你知道的），这太棒了。当然，有，这就是伯纳德·科恩韦尔小说的主情节，说讲英语的盎格鲁人或撒克逊人可以
sign up to this. You know, they can't go over to them. Well, almost certainly as Romano Britons would have done with the Anglo Saxons generations earlier. So this is all very bad news for the Mercians. And the King of Mercia, a guy called Burgred,
报名加入这个。你知道，他们可以投奔他们。好吧，几乎可以肯定罗马不列颠人几代人之前对盎格鲁撒克逊人做过的那样。所以这对麦西亚人来说都是非常糟糕的消息。麦西亚国王，一个叫伯格雷德的家伙，
eventually has enough and he decides he's off and he goes off and lives in Rome. He doesn't, he's also Prince Harry. He really, he doesn't. I think he's under slightly more pressure than Prince Harry, to be fair to him. And the Vikings set up a guy called Caelwolf, who gets roundly abused by the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle as a foolish thane.
最终受够了，他决定离开，去罗马生活。他没有，他也是哈里王子。他真的没有。我觉得公平地说，他承受的压力可能比哈里王子稍微大一点。而维京人扶植了一个叫切尔武夫的家伙，他在《盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史》中被狠狠地辱骂为一个愚蠢的塞恩。
I called him a mean and weaselly man in my children's book, Tom. But Dominic, we don't know. I know. I made it up. I mean, he must have been. He's a collaborator. Well, or the alternative is, you know, the vicious argument that he's struggling to do his best to maintain a kind of fig leaf of mercy and independence when we do that podcast about marshall payton tom are you
我在我的儿童书里叫他一个卑鄙、鬼祟的人，汤姆。但多米尼克，我们不知道。我知道。我编的。我的意思是，他一定是的。他是个合作者。好吧，或者另一种选择是，你知道，那种激烈的争论，即他在努力奋斗，以维持麦西亚独立的最后一块遮羞布，当我们做关于马歇尔·佩顿的播客时，汤姆，你
going to be getting all this stuff out he basically gets given gloucester yeah and there is evidence that he and alfred actually form a kind of alliance so they found a coin um minted in london london is a mercy and uh center showing alfred and kale wolf on it portrayed as two caesars implying that there's a kind of you know they have an equal dignity which doesn't equate with the way that subsequently in the anglo-saxon chronicle sponsored by alfred he is dismissed as this kind of idiot because by this point alfred is quite keen to take over mercy of course bring it under his authority so that again i think, I think is another example of the way in which Alfred is not this perfect gentleman. Well, it would be interesting, wouldn't it, just talking about the sources,
会把所有这些都挖出来吗？他基本上被赠予了格洛斯特，是的，有证据表明他和阿尔弗雷德实际上结成了一种同盟，所以他们发现了一枚硬币，在伦敦铸造的，伦敦是麦西亚的一个中心，上面描绘了阿尔弗雷德和切尔武夫，被描绘成两个凯撒，暗示着某种，你知道的，他们具有同等的尊严，这与后来在阿尔弗雷德资助的《盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史》中他被当作这种笨蛋被解雇的方式不符，因为到这个时候，阿尔弗雷德非常热衷于接管麦西亚，当然，将其置于他的统治之下，所以这再次，我认为，是阿尔弗雷德并非这个完美绅士的另一个例子。好吧，谈论这些历史资料会很有趣，不是吗，
if we had an equivalent to the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle written from outside Wessex. Well, we do have a Mercian. We do have Mercian accounts, but they don't write about this particular period. They're not as detailed, are they? They're not as colourful. But if you did have the equivalent, they might present a very different portrait of Alfred. They might see Alfred as a Wessex imperialist, I suppose. In due course, Alfred will go and capture London.
如果我们有一个从威塞克斯以外的角度撰写的与《盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史》相当的文献。嗯，我们确实有一个麦西亚的。我们确实有麦西亚的记录，但它们没有记载这个特定的时期。它们没有那么详细，对吧？它们没有那么丰富多彩。但如果你确实有同等地位的文献，它们可能会呈现出对阿尔弗雷德截然不同的画像。我想，它们可能会把阿尔弗雷德视为一个威塞克斯帝国主义者。在适当的时候，阿尔弗雷德会去攻占伦敦。
And there was evidently fighting in London, but it's not entirely clear who Alfred was fighting. People tend to assume it was the Vikings, but it may well have been the Mercians because it was a Mercian city. So I think that there is a sense that Alfred does acknowledge Caerwulf as an authentic Mercian king, but he also, of course, recognises that Caerwulf is basically, you know, I mean, he's so weak, he's so much a puppet that he's not really going to be much use
伦敦显然发生过战斗，但并不完全清楚阿尔弗雷德在与谁战斗。人们倾向于认为那是维京人，但很可能是麦西亚人，因为那是一座麦西亚城市。所以我认为有一种感觉，阿尔弗雷德确实承认切尔武夫是一个真正的麦西亚国王，但他也当然认识到切尔武夫基本上，你知道的，我的意思是，他是如此软弱，如此像一个傀儡，以至于他真的不会有什么大用处，
and that Wessex, therefore, is pretty much on its own it's the last kingdom so alfred let's get to 878 tom yeah alfred has been king now for seven years and so far he's done a solid job of staving off the vikings hasn't he by a combination of fighting and buying them off yeah he's preserved i suppose you would say the status quo is that fair yeah pretty much and there's he's had a lucky storm. So there's a great storm off the Dorset coast and it said 120 Viking ships are lost. So he's just about holding them out. And he gets them to, you know, he signs a treaty. They swap hostages. The Vikings withdraw.
以至于威塞克斯因此基本上只能靠自己了，它是最后一个王国，所以阿尔弗雷德，让我们来到878年，汤姆，是的，阿尔弗雷德当国王已经七年了，到目前为止，他在抵御维京人方面做得不错，不是吗？通过战斗和花钱打发他们相结合的方式，是的，他保持了，我想你会说是维持了现状，这样说公平吗？是的，差不多，而且他经历了一场幸运的风暴。所以多塞特海岸附近有一场大风暴，据说有120艘维京船只沉没。所以他勉强把他们挡住了。他让他们，你知道的，他签署了一项条约。他们交换人质。维京人撤退了。
It looks as though Wessex is you know i mean it's just about keeping its head above water and it's winter and by and large you don't fight in winter yeah and of course it's you have christmas in winter very very holy feast alfred very devout celebrates it and then you have the 12 days of christmas which you, we have celebrated in our own humble way, haven't we? With our episodes. And Alfred is celebrating 12th night at Chippenham, which is in North Wiltshire. And it's a great royal centre. And this is a holy feast day.
看起来威塞克斯（你知道我的意思）勉强维持着生计，而且现在是冬天，通常在冬天是不会打仗的，是的，当然冬天要过圣诞节，这是一个非常神圣的节日，阿尔弗雷德非常虔诚地庆祝它，然后是圣诞节的十二天，我们用我们自己卑微的方式庆祝过了，不是吗？通过我们的剧集。阿尔弗雷德正在北威尔特郡的奇彭纳姆庆祝圣诞节尾声，这是一个伟大的王室中心。这是一个神圣的节日。
He signed the peace treaty. It's the dead of winter. He assumes that everything's going to be fine. But the Vikings are cheats. Said it before, we'll say it again. They do not play by the rules and they launch an ambush. And this is absolutely standard Viking behavior. They love to attack people on Christian feast days because they know that the likelihood is that their enemies will be off guard.
他签署了和平条约。正值隆冬。他以为一切都会好起来的。但维京人是骗子。以前说过，我们还要再说一遍。他们不按规矩办事，他们发动了伏击。这绝对是标准的维京人行为。他们喜欢在基督教节日袭击别人，因为他们知道他们的敌人很可能处于无防备状态。
And this is exactly what happens and i think you could say that you know it's on or around um 12th night in 878 alfred is taken wholly by surprise he cannot stand and fight because if he does he'll be killed so he flees into the dark and the whole future of england is hanging by a thread oh it's so exciting hanging by a thread. Oh, it's so exciting. Hanging by a thread. It's a very dramatic moment. And if that thread had been cut, we'd all be, you know, we'd all be speaking Danish. Oh, I like Denmark actually, Tom.
而这正是发生的事情，我想你可以说，在878年圣诞节尾声当天或前后，阿尔弗雷德完全被打了个措手不及，他无法坚守抵抗，因为如果他那样做，他就会被杀，所以他逃入黑暗中，英格兰的整个未来悬于一线。哦，太激动人心了，悬于一线。哦，太激动人心了。悬于一线。这是一个非常戏剧性的时刻。如果那根线断了，我们大家都会，你知道的，我们都会说丹麦语。哦，其实我挺喜欢丹麦的，汤姆。
Brilliant tradition of kind of design. Lego and herring. Yeah. Yeah, it'd be wonderful. But it didn't happen. And as we will find out in Thursday's episode, Alfred will go on to prove himself the king least likely to win the Great British Bake Off, but very much the king most likely to save a kingdom that is tottering on its very foundations. Well, that's all to come on
有着辉煌的设计传统。乐高和鲱鱼。对。是的，那会很棒的。但它没有发生。正如我们在周四的节目中将要发现的，阿尔弗雷德将证明自己是最不可能赢得《英国烘焙大赛》的国王，但绝对是最有可能拯救一个摇摇欲坠的王国的国王。好吧，这些都将在
Thursday, isn't it, Tom? And of course, if you're a member of the Rest is History Club, you can listen to that right now. But before you do, we should end on a proper cliffhanger with a reading from Fury of the Vikings of what happened that night in Chippenham. So the Scullion boy has just gone outside, Tom, to relieve himself in the dead of night. And he's seen the Danes coming. Do you want to know what happens next?
周四揭晓，不是吗，汤姆？当然，如果你是《历史其余部分》俱乐部的会员，你现在就可以收听了。但在你这么做之前，我们应该以一个恰当的悬念结束，朗读一段《维京人的愤怒》中关于奇彭纳姆那个夜晚发生的事情。所以杂役男孩刚刚走到外面，汤姆，在万籁俱寂的深夜去解手。他看到了丹麦人正在走来。你想知道接下来发生什么吗？
I'd love to. As his desperate yells broke through the silence, the men in the hall were shaking themselves awake and calling for their weapons, and the servants were running to bar the doors, and the first axe blows were thundering into the timbers. It was all too late, for already the heathens were inside the hall, and people were screaming and shrieking, and there were bodies on the ground,
我很想知道。当他绝望的叫喊声打破了寂静时，大厅里的人们正摇晃着自己清醒过来，呼喊着他们的武器，仆人们跑去闩上门，第一批斧头砍进木头的声音雷鸣般响起。一切都太晚了，因为异教徒已经进入了大厅，人们在尖叫，地上躺着尸体，
and blood was soaking into the rugs on the floor. But when it was all over, and Guthrum walked in through the shattered doors, picking his way past the heaps of bodies and puddles of gore, one body was missing. For somehow, against all the odds, Alfred had escaped. Goodbye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. biz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
鲜血浸透了地上的小地毯。但当这一切结束，古斯伦穿过破碎的门走进来，小心翼翼地避开成堆的尸体和血泊时，却少了一具尸体。因为不知何故，在所有人都认为不可能的情况下，阿尔弗雷德逃脱了。再见。拜拜。感谢收听《历史其余部分》。想要获取独家单集、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。商业八卦，以及在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、独家单集和提前... 本集目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。